how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and everything relating to the
mcu
and lately the mcu hasn't had the best
of luck
thanks to the coronavirus marvel's phase
4 of the marvel cinematic universe has
had many different setbacks with many of
their projects including the falcon and
the winter soldier marvel studios black
widow the hawkeye series the one
division series and the loki series as
well
all of these have been delayed as well
as pretty much
all projects in phase four their dates
have been shifted back
and although it sucks that a lot of it
is up in the air right now we do have
word about when to expect
the wanda vision series to hit disney
plus and to top it all off we do have
some awesome
hawkeye news talking about hayley
steinfeld
and kate bishop so i'll break down
everything you need to know in this
video but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to the mcu and so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a dr doom funko pop
all you have to do to enter subscribe to
my channel like this video and leave a
comment about the video down below
so yesterday we got word that the falcon
and the winter soldier would not be
keeping its august release date and has
been postponed and unfortunately they
didn't give us a date in which they're
eyeing for it to actually be released
and this is the case for a lot of marvel
projects and unfortunately the wanda
vision series is going to take a hit as
well as it has been
delayed now the wanda vision series was
originally moved up from its original
date it was supposed to come out in 2021
but they moved it up to december of
2020.
now although it's sad that it has been
delayed there is some good news that
comes with this
they did give us a new release date of
when we could actually see the one
division series on disney plus
according to a report from the hollywood
reporter which is a very
very credible website instead of coming
in december of 2020 the one division
series is now set to arrive on disney
plus in spring of 2021
so luckily and hopefully it's only been
pushed back a few months
now for those of you thinking that we
may not get a trailer because of this
this doesn't necessarily mean that we
won't be getting a teaser trailer for
the one division show anytime soon in
fact we most likely will
in the hollywood reporters report they
do say that all of the filming for the
one division series has
wrapped meaning they have shot
everything that they need to shoot
so everything is in post-production now
what this means is that
marvel has all the footage that they
need to make a trailer
after all we did already see a little
teaser trailer during the super bowl so
marvel has everything they need to
release a trailer for the one division
series
and marvel definitely knows that all of
the marvel and mcu fans are suffering
right now we're super bummed that we
haven't got the black widow film
all of the disney plush shows have been
pushed back and really the entire
mcu phase 4 slate has been delayed they
know all of this and they're good to
their fans
and lately there's been a lot of reports
stating that we could be getting
a bunch of new trailers very soon so
fingers crossed for that and
like i said we'll end it on some good
news in regards to
the hawkeye series the hollywood
reporter has also reported that the
hawkeye series has found
a couple of directors as it turns out
the hawkeye series is going to be very
much like the mandalorian the
mandalorian had various different
directors for
different episodes and it turned out to
be fantastic
well that's apparently what they're
going to be doing with the hawkeye
series as well
and marvel studios has officially hired
amber finlayson and katie elwood to
direct a few episodes of the hawkeye
series and they've also hired
ryze thomas to direct a few episodes as
well but the most
interesting and most exciting part about
this report is what it mentions of kate
bishop
it says one of the arcs of the series is
barton's mentoring of a new generation
of archer
kate bishop haley steinfeld was
previously in negotiations for the part
but it's unclear if her deal is closed
marvel had no comment this is pretty
much the first time that we've got
an official confirmation that haley
steinfeld has actually spoke
with marvel studios and negotiated about
the role
everything else was pretty much
speculation and fan casting but this
report is
official now when the hollywood reporter
asked marvel if haley steinfeld was
going to be
kate bishop they had no comment which
means she's still in the running which
is great news because
haley steinfeld is pretty much the fan
favorite to play the role of kate bishop
so all of those reports that said she is
out and not playing the role she is not
out
yet but let me know what you think about
this news in the comments down below how
excited would you be to see hayley
steinfeld play kate bishop and let me
know which marvel phase 4 project you're
looking forward to the most
don't forget to give this video a like
and subscribe so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to the mcu and
what's happening don't forget to follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof